- Bentornato a Capire l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico.
Mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il Direttore Tecnico per
l'Educazione presso IBM Quantum.
Questa è la settima lezione della serie e in questa lezione discuteremo il problema della stima della fase e come possiamo risolverlo
con un computer quantistico.
Applicheremo poi la stima della fase al problema della fattorizzazione degli interi, di cui abbiamo parlato nella lezione precedente.
Quello che otterremo è l'algoritmo di Shor, che permette di
fattorizzare interi a costo polinomiale o in tempo polinomiale, se preferiamo
pensare in termini di tempo richiesto piuttosto che del numero di
operazioni elementari necessarie.
Questo è il gioiello della corona degli
algoritmi quantistici in un certo senso, e sebbene la fattorizzazione di grandi interi
possa avere utilità limitata per la maggior parte delle persone, rimane uno degli esempi più
convincenti che abbiamo per l'ipotesi che i computer quantistici offriranno vantaggi straordinari
rispetto ai computer classici. Ecco una panoramica della lezione.
Inizieremo con una definizione del problema della stima della fase stesso, e poi discuteremo un metodo per risolvere questo problema
con un computer quantistico.
Lo faremo un passo alla volta, iniziando con quello che puoi
considerare come una specie di riscaldamento.
Nel problema della stima della fase, l'obiettivo è approssimare
un certo numero reale e in questa parte di riscaldamento
vedremo come possiamo ottenere
un'approssimazione di precisione molto bassa
a questo numero.
Questo non sarà
sufficiente per la fattorizzazione quando applichiamo la nostra soluzione al
problema della stima della fase alla fattorizzazione degli interi,
avremo in realtà bisogno di un'approssimazione abbastanza precisa, ma è comunque utile iniziare con questo tipo di riscaldamento
solo per avere un'idea di
come funziona il tutto.
Discuteremo poi la questione di come possiamo ottenere più precisione, e questo porterà molto
naturalmente a un'operazione nota come la Trasformata di Fourier Quantistica.
Vedremo esattamente cos'è questa operazione e come può essere implementata
con un circuit quantistico.
E una volta che l'avremo, saremo in grado di applicarla
alla stima della fase per elaborare una procedura generale per risolvere il problema
con precisione molto alta.
Nell'ultima parte della lezione vedremo come una soluzione al
problema della stima della fase ci permette di fattorizzare interi in modo efficiente.
E nello specifico quello che otterremo è l'algoritmo di Shor per
la fattorizzazione degli interi, o almeno qualcosa di equivalente all'algoritmo di Shor.
Il modo in cui funziona è che ci diamo fondamentalmente
una pietra di passaggio, che è ancora un altro problema chiamato il problema del calcolo dell'ordine.
E in particolare vedremo come possiamo risolvere il problema del calcolo dell'ordine usando la procedura di stima della fase e poi vedremo come
possiamo fattorizzare interi
risolvendo il problema del calcolo dell'ordine. Inizieremo con un caso speciale di un teorema chiamato il Teorema Spettrale,
e nello specifico ci concentreremo su cosa ci dice il teorema
per le matrici unitarie.
Il teorema spettrale è
un teorema molto importante dell'algebra lineare e
dell'analisi funzionale.
Ci dice qualcosa di interessante su come certi mapping lineari possono essere espressi in una certa forma, spesso chiamata
decomposizione spettrale,
utile per molte ragioni.
E come ho detto, ci concentreremo su cosa ci dice questo teorema
per le matrici unitarie.
Il teorema spettrale è
più generale di questo. Non funziona per tutte le matrici, ma funziona per una classe di matrici
chiamate matrici normali, che includono tutte le matrici unitarie così come alcune matrici
che non sono unitarie.
Ma solo per semplicità, limiteremo la nostra attenzione
alle matrici unitarie per ora perché è tutto ciò di cui abbiamo bisogno per
gli scopi di questa lezione.
Ecco un enunciato del teorema spettrale solo per le matrici unitarie.
Supponiamo che U sia una
matrice unitaria N per N.
Quello che il teorema dice
è che deve esistere una base ortonormale di
vettori, psi uno attraverso psi N,
insieme a N numeri complessi
Lambda uno attraverso Lambda N, tutti giacenti sul cerchio unitario complesso, così che U può essere espresso
come abbiamo in questa equazione.
Questa si chiama decomposizione spettrale
di U, come ho già menzionato, e può essere molto comodo sapere che U può essere scritto in questo modo.
A volte può essere comodo avere questi vettori e questi numeri quando lavoriamo con
una particolare matrice unitaria U, e può anche essere molto
utile semplicemente sapere
che tale espressione è sempre possibile come modo di dimostrare certe cose sulle matrici unitarie, ad esempio.
In questo enunciato del teorema, ciascuno di questi numeri,
Lambda uno attraverso lambda N, è scritto in un modo particolare
come E alla potenza due pi I volte theta dove ciascuno dei theta
theta uno attraverso theta N è un numero reale, e
torneremo su questo modo
di scrivere ciascuno di questi
numeri tra poco.
Una cosa importante da notare
riguardo a questi vettori e numeri è che ogni vettore psi
K deve essere un autovettore della matrice U con
autovalore corrispondente lambda K.
Il che significa che se
moltiplichiamo psi K per U, quello che otteniamo è lambda K volte psi K.
Quindi quello che U fa a ciascuno di questi vettori è semplicemente moltiplicarlo per il numero corrispondente lambda K.
In generale per un vettore arbitrario, questo non è come funziona U, ma gli autovettori sono speciali.
E quello che il teorema ci dice è che esiste in effetti
una base ortonormale di questi autovettori.
Questa equazione qui sotto, tra l'altro, segue dall'espressione che abbiamo per U dal teorema, insieme al fatto che
i vettori sono ortonormali.
WEBVTT
Se moltiplichi l'espressione di U a qualsiasi psi K e usi l'ortonormalità dei vettori, otterrai una somma in cui
tutti i termini sono zero
tranne uno di essi, e l'unico termine che ci
rimane è così.
Ora possiamo definire il
problema della stima della fase.
Il problema è un po'
insolito come vedremo.
Ci vengono date due cose. Prima, ci viene data la descrizione di un circuit quantistico unitario,
che agisce su N qubit
per una certa scelta di N, e quando diciamo che questo
è un circuit unitario,
intendiamo semplicemente che tutti i
gate sono unitari, quindi non ci sono misurazioni
in questo circuit.
Secondo, ci viene dato uno stato psi di N qubit, e questa è la parte insolita.
Abbiamo effettivamente uno stato
quantistico come input per questo problema, ed è una singola copia di questo stato.
Per tutti gli altri problemi computazionali di cui abbiamo parlato in questa serie, l'input era classico, sia nella forma di una stringa
di bit che come scatola nera.
E questo non sorprende perché i problemi computazionali
che incontriamo nella nostra vita quotidiana tendono ad essere classici,
perché sono i
problemi che ci interessano di più.
Il modo in cui puoi
pensare a questo problema è che si tratta di qualcosa che appare o è probabile che appaia come un sotto-problema.
E la procedura di stima della fase che alla fine elaboreremo è qualcosa che
generalmente usiamo come subroutine
all'interno di un calcolo più ampio, presumibilmente uno per un problema classico
di cui ci occupiamo.
Ora, questo sarà un problema promise e lo stato psi non è
uno qualsiasi stato quantistico.
Ci viene promesso che psi è un autovettore di qualsiasi operazione unitaria U sia quella che il circuit dato descrive.
E l'obiettivo è trovare o
approssimare l'autovalore che corrisponde all'autovettore psi.
Enunciamo il problema in modo un po'
più preciso.
L'input consiste in un circuit
quantistico unitario su N qubit, che può essere codificato come una stringa di bit
usando qualsiasi metodo preferiamo per codificare le descrizioni di circuit quantistici, insieme a uno stato psi di N qubit.
Possiamo chiamare il circuit come vogliamo, ma quello che conta davvero in termini di enunciato di questo problema è l'operazione unitaria stessa
che viene eseguita quando il circuit è in esecuzione, e quella operazione unitaria
è descritta dalla Matrice U.
Ma non ci viene dato U come matrice, ci viene data solo la descrizione di un circuit quantistico che implementa U.
La promise, come ho già detto, è che psi è un autovettore di U.
Quindi se eseguissimo il nostro circuit su psi, otterremmo psi in uscita moltiplicato per qualsiasi sia l'autovalore,
che sarebbe una fase globale
in quella situazione.
E infine, l'output del problema è un'approssimazione all'autovalore corrispondente a psi, e nello specifico stiamo cercando
un'approssimazione al numero reale theta, tra zero e uno, incluso
zero, ma non incluso uno
che soddisfa l'equazione
che abbiamo sullo schermo.
Per spiegare questo modo di
parametrizzare l'autovalore corrispondente a pis, e anche per chiarire cosa intendiamo per approssimazione,
disegniamo un'immagine del
cerchio unitario complesso.
Possiamo mettere i numeri uno, I,
meno uno e meno I nei loro soliti posti e possiamo considerare
un punto arbitrario sul
cerchio parametrizzato da theta come abbiamo nell'enunciato del problema.
Questo è il punto che
otteniamo se partiamo da uno e ruotiamo di un angolo di
due volte pi volte theta, quindi l'angolo non è
theta, è due pi theta,
e un altro modo di pensarci è che se partiamo da uno e percorriamo una distanza di due pi theta sul cerchio stesso,
arriveremo al nostro punto, E al
due volte pi volte theta.
Ogni punto nel cerchio unitario complesso può essere rappresentato in questo modo
per una scelta unica di theta.
Ed è perché percorriamo
tutto il cerchio man mano che theta va da zero a uno, e se andassimo tutto
fino a theta uguale a uno,
saremmo tornati dove
eravamo partiti con theta uguale a zero, ecco perché includiamo zero, ma non includiamo uno.
Solo per assicurarci che ogni
punto sul cerchio unitario complesso corrisponda a un valore unico di theta nell'intervallo che stiamo considerando.
Ci sono vari modi
in cui potremmo immaginare di approssimare un particolare valore di theta, ma il modo in cui lo faremo è di approssimare theta con una frazione,
dove il denominatore
è due alla potenza M per una certa scelta di un intero positivo M, e il numeratore è un intero y
tra zero e due alla M meno uno.
Puoi pensarla come un'approssimazione a M bit di theta se vuoi, e potremmo scrivere questo
numero in notazione binaria
dove abbiamo un punto binario seguito dalla rappresentazione
binaria di Y.
Dico punto binario tra l'altro
piuttosto che punto decimale perché decimale significa base 10 e sto parlando di base due
qui, ma l'idea è la stessa.
Ma in ogni caso possiamo
anche pensarla semplicemente come una frazione come appare
sullo schermo.
E per essere chiari, quando pensiamo alle
approssimazioni in questo contesto, si dovrebbe capire
che i valori di theta
WEBVTT
vicini a zero e i valori di theta vicini a uno sono in realtà vicini tra loro.
Ad esempio, se theta è uguale a 0.99 e approssimiamo questo valore
di theta con il valore zero,
quella è un'approssimazione abbastanza buona nel senso che è
entro un centesimo del valore reale, quando
percorriamo il cerchio
e torniamo a zero quando arriviamo a uno.
Il termine modulo uno viene a volte usato per descrivere la situazione, dove sostanzialmente
equipariamo theta uguale a uno con theta uguale a zero.
Il punto è che ci importa davvero della posizione del punto
E al due pi I theta sul cerchio unitario,
e pensare a questo
modo di approssimare theta ha senso quando abbiamo quell'obiettivo in mente.
L'enunciato del problema stesso,
come appare sullo schermo, non è specifico su quanto buona debba essere l'approssimazione di theta,
ma è qualcosa che possiamo affinare a seconda delle nostre esigenze.
In alcune situazioni potremmo essere soddisfatti di un'approssimazione a bassa precisione
di theta, e in altre situazioni potremmo richiedere
un'approssimazione ad alta precisione, e l'enunciato del problema stesso
può essere raffinato di conseguenza.
Ora vedremo come possiamo risolvere
il problema della stima della fase con un computer quantistico e
inizieremo con un riscaldamento.
Questa non sarà la nostra soluzione finale
al problema.
Quello che faremo è sfruttare il fenomeno del phase kickback per cercare di imparare qualcosa
sull'autovalore corrispondente a un dato autovettore.
Ricorda che nel
problema della stima della fase ci viene data la descrizione
di un circuit quantistico unitario per qualche operazione U,
e quello che facciamo prima è
usare questa descrizione del circuit per creare un nuovo circuit che implementa un'operazione U controllata come
è raffigurato sullo schermo.
Questo è abbastanza semplice da fare. Quello che possiamo fare è aggiungere un qubit di controllo, raffigurato in
alto in questo diagramma
e usare questo nuovo qubit
di controllo come controllo per ogni singolo gate che
appare nel nostro circuit.
Quindi tutti i gate vengono applicati se questo qubit di controllo è impostato a uno, e nessuno di essi viene applicato se il qubit di controllo è impostato a zero,
il che significa che avremo
bisogno di una versione controllata di ogni gate che
appare nel circuit U, ma non dobbiamo pensare
a questi nuovi gate controllati
come gate singoli se non vogliamo. Potrebbero essere implementati
come piccoli circuit fatti di gate da qualsiasi insieme di gate
che abbiamo scelto di usare. E una volta che abbiamo una
versione controllata di U, possiamo considerare di eseguire questo circuit,
dove prima mettiamo il qubit di controllo in una sovrapposizione di zero e uno, applichiamo il gate U controllato all'autovettore che ci è stato dato,
e poi applichiamo un gate Hadamard
al controllo e misuriamo.
Vedremo perché ha senso fare questo mentre andiamo attraverso l'analisi, ma anche prima di arrivare ai dettagli, possiamo immediatamente vedere una somiglianza
con l'algoritmo di Deutsch ad esempio, dove stiamo applicando un
paio di gate Hadamard e misuriamo come modo
di sondare effettivamente
quello che una certa
operazione sta facendo qui.
È un unitario controllato
piuttosto che un gate di query, ma ci sono idee molto simili in gioco.
Quindi vediamo cosa fa il circuit.
Lo stato iniziale è l'autovettore psi, in prodotto tensoriale con lo stato zero
per il qubit di controllo,
applicare il primo gate Hadamard trasforma lo stato del
qubit in alto in uno stato più e possiamo espandere l'intero
stato come è mostrato qui.
Poi applichiamo l'operazione U controllata e quello che fa è applicare U a psi quando il qubit di controllo è impostato a uno,
ma non quando è impostato a zero. Quindi otteniamo lo stato pi due
che è scritto sullo schermo.
Possiamo semplificare lo stato
usando il fatto che psi è un autovettore di U con autovalore e al due pi I theta.
Quindi otteniamo quell'autovalore che moltiplica il secondo
termine, ma non il primo.
E possiamo semplificare usando la bilinearità
del prodotto tensoriale.
Quindi quello che abbiamo qui è il fenomeno del phase kickback, ma questa volta sta accadendo per qualche autovettore arbitrario psi di qualche operazione unitaria arbitraria U,
al contrario di un'operazione NOT applicata a uno stato meno più nello specifico.
Quindi questo è lo stato dopo che l'operazione U controllata viene applicata.
A proposito, vale la pena
prendersi un momento per notare che lo stato degli N qubit in basso è ancora l'autovettore psi.
Il che è ottimo perché ci
dà l'opportunità di usarlo di nuovo se scegliamo.
Poi viene eseguito il secondo gate Hadamard ed ecco lo stato che otteniamo.
Non ho mostrato tutti i
dettagli della derivazione qui, ma se applichi il
gate Hadamard e semplifichi, questo è quello che dovresti ottenere.
Quindi questo è lo stato appena
prima della misurazione.
Quindi possiamo concentrarci su questo stato per vedere cosa possiamo imparare
su theta misurando.
E se misuriamo il qubit in alto
o il qubit più a destra, queste sono le probabilità che otteniamo per i due risultati.
E qui ho usato un
paio di formule di base che mettono in relazione seni e coseni
con gli esponenziali complessi per esprimere queste probabilità
in termini di seni e coseni.
In modo specifico, la probabilità di ottenere zero è il coseno quadrato di pi volte theta e la probabilità di ottenere uno
WEBVTT
è il seno quadrato dello stesso angolo. E questo ha senso
perché il seno quadrato più il coseno quadrato di
qualsiasi angolo è uguale a uno.
Quindi le nostre probabilità
sommano a uno come ci aspettiamo.
Ed ecco un grafico di queste probabilità in funzione di theta.
Per essere chiari, questo è un grafico delle
probabilità stesse al contrario di un grafico che raffigura una singola distribuzione di probabilità ad esempio.
Ad esempio, se theta
è uguale a un mezzo, allora la probabilità di ottenere il risultato uno disegnato in viola è uguale a uno
mentre la probabilità
di ottenere il risultato zero, disegnato in blu, è zero.
D'altra parte, se theta è uguale a un
quarto o tre quarti, allora i due risultati sono ugualmente probabili.
E ovviamente per tutte le scelte di theta, la somma delle probabilità è uguale a uno come abbiamo già osservato.
Quindi non sappiamo esattamente quale
sia theta da questa procedura, ma ci dà alcune
informazioni su theta.
E se immaginiamo una situazione in cui ci viene promesso
che theta è uguale a zero o theta è uguale a un mezzo, questa procedura ci dirà
esattamente quale delle
due possibilità sia.
Quindi questo è un modo semplice in cui possiamo usare il fenomeno del phase kickback per imparare qualcosa sull'autovalore.
Quindi come possiamo imparare di più
sull'autovalore?
Beh, questa è una situazione in cui possiamo lasciare che
l'ignoranza ci guidi.
Perché in realtà non ci sono
troppe cose che possiamo fare.
Non sappiamo quasi nulla
sull'autovettore sin, e non sappiamo molto
neppure dell'operazione U.
Abbiamo un circuit per U, ma per quello che sappiamo potrebbe essere
un groviglio orribile e confuso di cui non riusciremo a capire
nulla esaminandolo.
Ma un'opzione naturale è eseguire il circuit più volte.
In particolare, potremmo provare a fare esattamente la stessa cosa che abbiamo appena fatto, tranne che invece di applicare una sola operazione U controllata,
applichiamo quella operazione due volte. Oppure potremmo applicarla un qualsiasi numero di volte, ma iniziamo con due
solo per vedere cosa succede.
Beh, è in realtà abbastanza
semplice quello che succede. Applicando l'operazione U
controllata due volte, stiamo essenzialmente solo
elevando al quadrato l'autovalore
perché verrà inserito nella
fase del qubit in alto due volte invece di una sola.
E quindi quando pensiamo alle
probabilità di risultato in funzione di theta, stiamo essenzialmente solo
raddoppiando la frequenza.
Per ogni possibile scelta di theta, le probabilità di risultato
sono le stesse di quelle che avremmo se raddoppiassimo theta e poi prendessimo la parte frazionaria
per ottenere un numero tra zero e uno.
Ad esempio, se theta
è uguale a un mezzo, allora l'autovalore è meno uno.
Quindi applicando U due volte stiamo effettivamente elevando al quadrato l'autovalore e il risultato è lo stesso di quello che sarebbe per theta uguale a zero.
Il che significa che la probabilità
per il risultato zero, raffigurata in blu, è uguale a uno, e la probabilità per il risultato uno, raffigurata in viola, è uguale a zero.
Questo è molto semplice, ma possiamo in effetti ottenere
alcune informazioni aggiuntive su theta facendo questo.
Ad esempio, se sappiamo in anticipo che theta è uguale a zero o theta è uguale a un quarto, allora questo circuit ci rivelerà
quale delle due possibilità sia.
D'altra parte, non possiamo più distinguere il caso in cui theta è uguale a zero dal caso in cui theta è uguale a un mezzo.
Quindi questa procedura non è strettamente migliore di quella precedente quando
avevamo un solo gate U di controllo, ma eseguendo anche questo circuit
possiamo ottenere informazioni aggiuntive.
Non è immediatamente chiaro
come le informazioni aggiuntive che possiamo ottenere iterando l'operazione U controllata più volte
possano essere conciliate con
le informazioni che otteniamo eseguendola solo una volta, e in realtà ci sono diversi
modi in cui potremmo procedere.
Ad esempio, c'è una tecnica chiamata stima della fase iterativa, che prevede l'esecuzione di circuit come quelli che abbiamo visto,
insieme ad alcune varianti minori su di essi, per elaborare un'approssimazione di theta.
Ma descriverò
quello che potrebbe essere chiamato un approccio più tradizionale, dove usiamo un singolo circuit quantistico che ha più qubit di controllo
che controllano diversi
numeri di iterazioni dell'operazione unitaria U.
Prima descriverò come funziona
per due qubit di controllo e poi un po' più avanti lo generalizzeremo a più di due qubit di controllo.
Ecco un circuit quantistico
che usa due qubit di controllo.
Il qubit di controllo in alto
controlla una singola operazione U mentre il qubit
secondo dall'alto controlla due copie di U.
Quindi quello che stiamo facendo è combinare i due circuit che abbiamo visto in precedenza, in un modo che sfrutta la singola copia
dell'autovettore psi che abbiamo.
Noterai tuttavia
che i gate Hadamard dopo le operazioni U
controllate sono stati rimossi e non ci sono ancora misurazioni.
Quello che faremo è
vedere come funziona questo circuit e poi capiremo
cosa dovremmo fare con i due qubit in alto
per imparare il più possibile sul valore theta che
stiamo cercando di approssimare.
Dopo i gate Hadamard eseguiti, avevamo lo stato mostrato
sullo schermo.
WEBVTT
E questo sarà un modo conveniente di scrivere lo stato per
vedere cosa succede dopo.
A zero e A uno sono bit, e se pensiamo ai due qubit in alto come un registro a due qubit,
stiamo pensando ad A zero, che corrisponde al qubit in alto come il bit meno significativo, e A uno che corrisponde
al qubit di controllo in basso
come il bit più significativo.
Dopo che la prima operazione U
controllata viene eseguita, otteniamo questo stato.
Lo stato classico corrispondente al qubit di controllo in alto è a zero, quindi il risultato del phase kickback
può essere espresso in questo modo. Poi dopo la seconda e
la terza operazione U controllata
vengono eseguite, otteniamo questo stato.
L'idea è la stessa della prima, tranne che questa volta stiamo applicando l'operazione U di controllo due volte.
Quindi moltiplichiamo A uno per due nel
esponente per riflettere questo.
E ora possiamo semplificare questa espressione pensando ai bit
A uno e A zero insieme come un intero tra zero e
tre usando la notazione binaria.
Ovvero quando pensiamo
alla stringa di due bit, A uno A zero, come la
codifica binaria di un intero,
quello che otteniamo è due
volte A uno più A zero.
E la comprensione è
che quando scriviamo Cat X, stiamo parlando di X scritto come stringa binaria di lunghezza
due usando la notazione binaria.
Ora concentriamoci su
questi due qubit di controllo per capire cosa possiamo
imparare su theta da essi in questo momento.
Gli N qubit rimanenti sono
ancora nello stesso stato psi che ci era stato originariamente dato, il che è davvero una cosa meravigliosa di questo approccio
perché come ho detto prima, possiamo usare quello stato di nuovo se vogliamo ottenere ancora più
informazioni su theta.
Ma per ora, pensiamo solo a cosa possiamo imparare da
questi due qubit di controllo.
Per aiutarci a capire come procedere, immaginiamo che ci venga promesso che theta è uguale a Y su quattro
per qualche intero y tra zero e tre.
In generale, theta potrebbe non essere
uno di questi quattro valori, ma questo è un caso naturale da considerare.
Abbiamo visto nella versione originale con un solo qubit di controllo della procedura che se ci veniva promesso che theta è zero o un mezzo
il circuit avrebbe rivelato quale fosse. E abbiamo anche notato che nella versione dove abbiamo applicato l'operazione U controllata due volte,
potevamo discriminare perfettamente il caso che theta è uguale a zero dal caso che theta
è uguale a un quarto.
Quindi potremmo sperare che con il nostro nuovo circuit possiamo discriminare questi quattro casi.
In sostanza, quello che stiamo
facendo è usare la nozione di un problema promise
per rendere il problema più facile, così da poter vedere come procedere.
E questa non è una cattiva idea, in generale. Se hai un problema e non
sai come risolverlo, prova a renderlo più facile.
Se riesci a risolvere il problema più semplice, l'intuizione che guadagni potrebbe essere utile per risolvere il problema più generale.
E se non riesci a risolvere il problema più semplice, probabilmente non sei pronto
per il problema più generale.
Quindi continua a renderlo più facile
finché non riesci a risolverlo.
In ogni caso, tornando al nostro problema, definiamo uno stato a due qubit per ciascuno dei possibili valori di Y.
In altre parole, phi Y è uguale allo stato
mostrato in cima allo schermo quando theta è scelto
specificamente come Y su quattro.
Ed ecco quei quattro
stati scritti esplicitamente.
Quindi solo per ribadire, se
theta è uguale a Y su quattro per Y uguale a zero, uno, due, o
tre e eseguiamo il nostro circuit,
rimarremo con
uno di questi quattro stati, quello che corrisponde
al giusto valore di Y.
E vogliamo solo capire
quale sia.
E la domanda è, è possibile?
E la risposta a quella domanda è sì, perché questi quattro stati sono ortogonali.
Se calcoli il prodotto interno
tra qualsiasi coppia di essi, otterrai zero.
E poiché sono ortogonali, possono essere discriminati perfettamente con una misurazione proiettiva.
E in particolare possiamo
esprimere tale misurazione definendo una proiezione per ogni vettore come abbiamo qui.
Questo funziona sempre, ogni volta
che abbiamo una base ortonormale, e puoi verificarlo
rispetto alle definizioni che abbiamo visto nella lezione tre
per questo caso specifico
se sei incline a farlo. Quindi concludiamo che è
possibile svolgere il nostro compito,
che è imparare il valore di Y dallo stato mostrato
in cima allo schermo.
E se vogliamo farlo
con un circuit quantistico, possiamo procedere come spiegherò ora.
Prima possiamo definire una matrice unitaria V le cui colonne sono i quattro
vettori elencati in ordine.
Quella matrice avrà l'azione descritta nella parte bassa dello schermo,
sugli stati della base standard,
e possiamo scrivere la matrice
per vedere come appare.
Poiché V mappa ogni stato della base standard, kappa Y al vettore phi Y, abbiamo che applicando V dagger,
o in altre parole V inverso a phi Y si trasformerà nel modo opposto allo stato corrispondente della base standard.
WEBVTT
Quindi quello che possiamo fare è applicare V dagger a qualsiasi stato ottenuto dal nostro circuit.
E poi se eseguiamo una
misurazione della base standard, otterremo il numero Y
che stiamo cercando, espresso come una stringa
di lunghezza due in binario.
Prima di andare avanti, parliamo un po' di più
della matrice unitaria V.
Questa è una matrice speciale e
potresti averla già vista prima.
È la matrice associata
a un'operazione lineare su vettori a quattro dimensioni nota come trasformata discreta di Fourier.
Per essere più precisi, la trasformata discreta di Fourier può essere definita per qualsiasi
dimensione intera positiva, e ne daremo un'occhiata
in generale tra poco.
E questo è il suo aspetto specificamente quando la dimensione è uguale a quattro.
Possiamo pensare alla
trasformata discreta di Fourier in diversi modi.
Possiamo pensarci in modo puramente astratto come un mapping lineare su vettori che può essere rappresentato da una matrice.
E possiamo anche pensarci
come un problema computazionale dove ci viene dato un vettore, e vogliamo calcolare il risultato
di applicare questo mapping lineare.
Si rivela essere un problema computazionale incredibilmente importante,
e c'è un algoritmo altamente efficiente per eseguire quel calcolo
noto come la trasformata rapida di Fourier.
In realtà, questo è un problema così importante nell'elaborazione del segnale ad esempio, che la trasformata rapida di Fourier
è considerata da molti
come uno degli algoritmi più importanti e significativi
mai scoperti.
Possiamo anche pensare alla
trasformata discreta di Fourier come un'operazione quantistica unitaria che può essere applicata a
un vettore di stato quantistico.
E quando la pensiamo in quel modo, la chiamiamo trasformata di Fourier quantistica,
o QFT in breve.
Matematicamente parlando, è essenzialmente la stessa cosa della trasformata discreta di Fourier, ma la chiamiamo trasformata di Fourier quantistica
solo per chiarire che è un'operazione applicata a un vettore di stato quantistico.
Quindi cambiamo il nome della nostra matrice, da V a QFT quattro per riflettere il fatto
che l'operazione che abbiamo elaborato è in effetti la trasformata di Fourier quantistica.
Quindi ecco il circuit completo per imparare il valore di Y quando ci viene promesso che
theta è uguale a Y su quattro
per Y uguale a zero, uno, due, o tre.
E solo per assicurarsi che sia chiaro, stiamo applicando l'inverso della
trasformata di Fourier quantistica, o in altre parole QFT quattro dagger
per mappare uno dei quattro possibili stati di nuovo allo stato della base standard, cat Y, così da poter recuperare Y misurando.
Quindi questo è il circuit che
otteniamo pensando alla versione promise del
problema della stima della fase, dove ci viene promesso che theta
è zero, un quarto, un
mezzo o tre quarti, ma non c'è nulla che ci impedisca
di eseguire questo circuit per
un valore arbitrario di theta.
E se lo facciamo, ecco
le probabilità per i quattro possibili
risultati che otteniamo.
Ciascuno dei quattro possibili
valori per Y ha il suo colore, e il grafico ci dice
quali sono le probabilità per ciascuno in funzione di theta.
Quindi ad esempio, se theta
è uguale a tre quarti, otterremo il risultato
tre con probabilità uno,
mentre le probabilità per gli altri tre risultati sono tutte zero come sappiamo già pensando alla versione promise del problema.
Se theta è vicino a tre quarti ma non esattamente tre quarti, ci sarà una probabilità non nulla associata agli altri risultati,
ma otterremo comunque il risultato
tre con alta probabilità.
Quindi anche se theta potrebbe
non essere uguale a Y su quattro, possiamo comunque pensare
al risultato che otteniamo dalle misurazioni diviso per quattro
come una supposizione o un'approssimazione
per theta.
La supposizione potrebbe essere sbagliata, ma comunque ci
fornisce informazioni.
E una cosa che possiamo
imparare dal grafico è che le migliori approssimazioni hanno sempre le più alte
probabilità associate a esse.
Quando dico migliore approssimazione, intendo qualsiasi valore di Y su quattro che sia più vicino al vero valore di theta,
nel senso modulo uno. Il caso peggiore è che theta sia esattamente a metà tra
due valori di Y su quattro.
Ad esempio, se theta è uguale
a tre ottavi o 0.375, in questo caso vediamo
che le approssimazioni
un quarto e due quarti
o un mezzo sono ugualmente buone.
Quindi in questo particolare
caso ci sono in realtà due migliori approssimazioni invece di una.
E siamo ugualmente propensi a ottenere il risultato uno
e il risultato due.
Gli altri due risultati zero e tre, che non danno approssimazioni molto buone
a theta quando dividiamo per quattro, appaiono effettivamente con una certa probabilità
che sembra essere appena
sotto il 10% in entrambi i casi.
Quindi questa procedura non è perfetta, ma ci fornisce informazioni.
Ed è notevole che
indipendentemente da theta, abbiamo sempre la garanzia di ottenere la migliore approssimazione
o una delle due migliori approssimazioni quando c'è un pareggio, con una probabilità che
sembra essere appena sopra il 40%.
WEBVTT
E quanto più theta è
vicino all'approssimazione, tanto più alta è la probabilità di vedere il valore corrispondente di Y.
E questo è un miglioramento piuttosto
significativo rispetto all'uso di un singolo qubit di controllo.
Questa è in effetti la procedura di stima
della fase quando scegliamo di usare due qubit di controllo.
E quello che faremo dopo è generalizzare questa
procedura in modo naturale, dove non ci fermiamo con
solo due qubit di controllo
ma usiamo quanti
qubit di controllo vogliamo.
E quello che vedremo è che
generalizzando la procedura, aggiungendo più qubit di controllo, saremo in grado di ottenere approssimazioni sempre più
accurate di theta. E questa sarà la procedura generale
di stima della fase.
Per generalizzare la
procedura di stima della fase da due qubit di controllo
a quanti ne scegliamo, dovremo capire
come viene definita la trasformata di Fourier quantistica per altre dimensioni.
E dovremo anche discutere come può essere implementata
con un circuit quantistico.
Ecco la definizione della
trasformata di Fourier quantistica quando la dimensione è un
intero positivo arbitrario N.
Qui stiamo pensando a questa operazione come un'operazione su un sistema i cui stati classici sono
da zero a N meno uno.
E qui la matrice che
descrive questa operazione è stata espressa usando
la notazione diretta.
Possiamo anche descriverla in termini della sua azione
sugli stati della base standard, solo per collegarla con
quello che abbiamo già visto quando N è uguale a quattro.
Quindi ecco come appare
quando N è uguale a uno, che non è un caso molto interessante.
Eccolo per N uguale a due, e noterai che quello che otteniamo in questo caso è un'operazione Hadamard.
Ecco la trasformata di Fourier quantistica
per N uguale a tre.
Per N uguale a quattro, che
abbiamo già visto.
E per un ultimo esempio, eccolo quando N è uguale a otto.
Proprio come avevamo prima
per il caso N uguale a quattro, queste sono le matrici che associamo alla trasformata discreta di Fourier
per ciascuna delle dimensioni. Ma la chiamiamo
trasformata di Fourier quantistica quando vogliamo pensarci
come un'operazione quantistica.
A volte tra l'altro, il fattore principale di uno su radice quadrata di N non è incluso quando pensiamo alla trasformata discreta di Fourier
come matrice,
ma abbiamo bisogno di quel fattore qui per assicurarci di ottenere una matrice unitaria.
C'è anche a volte un segno meno in ciascuno degli esponenti, ma non sempre.
È fondamentalmente solo una preferenza personale che non cambia la natura fondamentale
della trasformata.
Ma in ogni caso, definiremo la trasformata di Fourier quantistica come è scritta qui sullo schermo.
C'è una notazione abbreviata molto utile
che è comune e la useremo
un po' più avanti nella lezione.
E cioè definire un
numero complesso omega N, come abbiamo qui.
Specificamente come e al due pi I su N, che può anche essere scritto
usando seni e coseni
come abbiamo qui. A volte chiamiamo questo
numero una radice N-esima dell'unità perché quando lo eleviamo
alla potenza N, otteniamo uno.
Ecco una figura che mostra alcuni esempi.
Omega uno è uguale a uno, omega due è uguale a meno uno, e omega quattro è uguale a I.
In generale per ottenere omega N, possiamo immaginare di dividere il cerchio unitario in N pezzi di uguali dimensioni come se fosse una pizza condivisa tra N persone
e omega N è all'
angolo del primo pezzo, assumendo che l'altro angolo
di quel pezzo sia a uno.
Quindi in particolare man mano che N
diventa sempre più grande, i pezzi diventeranno sempre più piccoli, e omega N si avvicinerà
sempre più a uno.
E ora se usiamo quella notazione possiamo esprimere la
trasformata di Fourier quantistica in modo leggermente più pulito.
A volte questa notazione
aiuta a mantenere le cose semplici come vedremo accadere
un po' più avanti nella lezione.
C'è un'implementazione efficiente con circuit quantistico della trasformata di Fourier quantistica
quando N è una potenza di due,
che esamineremo ora. Sebbene tendiamo a definire la
trasformata di Fourier quantistica per qualsiasi dimensione N,
ne avremo bisogno solo
nel caso in cui N sia una potenza di due, per generalizzare la
procedura di stima della fase.
L'implementazione farà
uso di gate di fase controllati che sono raffigurati come
abbiamo qui sullo schermo.
Sembrano due
controlli collegati insieme insieme a un numero che
è alpha in questo caso.
E l'azione di questo gate è descritta dalla matrice mostrata qui.
Questi sono letteralmente
gate di fase controllati, nel senso che abbiamo un qubit di controllo che controlla un gate di fase.
Abbiamo visto i gate di fase molto indietro nella lezione uno.
Ma per i gate di fase specificamente, in realtà non importa
quale qubit sia il controllo e quale sia il target.
E lo abbiamo visto nella lezione due, per il caso specifico di un gate Z.
E ora che abbiamo quel concetto, possiamo passare a come la
trasformata di Fourier quantistica può essere implementata.
WEBVTT
L'implementazione è di natura ricorsiva e forse il modo più semplice
per descriverla in termini semplici è fare un esempio che
può essere facilmente generalizzato.
Ecco come possiamo farlo
quando N è uguale a 32.
Quindi ci sono cinque qubit.
Per essere chiari, stiamo associando gli
stati della base standard di questi cinque qubit con gli interi tra zero e 31 usando la notazione binaria.
La prima cosa che facciamo è eseguire la trasformata di Fourier
quantistica per N uguale a 16 su tutti i qubit tranne
il qubit meno significativo,
che è quello in cima. E questa è la parte
ricorsiva della costruzione.
Quindi per implementare questa operazione, dobbiamo seguire lo stesso
schema ma con un qubit in meno.
E nel caso base abbiamo
solo un singolo qubit per il quale la trasformata di Fourier quantistica è solo un gate Hadamard.
Una volta applicato il QFT su tutti i qubit tranne il primo in alto, applichiamo un insieme di gate di fase controllati usando le fasi che sono
indicate nel diagramma.
Poi applichiamo un gate Hadamard
al qubit in alto, e mescoliamo un po' i qubit usando alcuni gate swap.
Questi gate swap hanno l'effetto di permutare ciclicamente i qubit, necessario per far
funzionare la costruzione.
Possiamo seguire esattamente lo stesso schema per altre scelte di N
purché siano potenze di due, dove iniziamo sempre i gate di fase controllati
con alpha uguale a pi su
due per il qubit in basso e dividendo per due ogni volta
spostandosi a sinistra nel diagramma
per ottenere le fasi successive. Ora non è affatto ovvio
che questa costruzione funzioni.
E non spiegherò
perché funziona in questo video.
Se sei interessato a vedere
i dettagli del perché funziona, puoi trovarli nel
contenuto scritto della lezione.
Dirò comunque che
quello che viene sfruttato qui è la struttura di base delle
trasformate discrete di Fourier
e in realtà è esattamente
la stessa struttura che consente alla trasformata rapida
di Fourier di funzionare.
Un altro modo per dirlo è che se guardiamo la trasformata rapida di Fourier, possiamo pensarci in
termini di circuit quantistici.
E questo è il circuit che otteniamo.
Quindi quanti gate servono in totale per questa implementazione?
Per capirlo, facciamo che SM sia il numero di gate di cui
abbiamo bisogno quando abbiamo M qubit.
Quando M è uguale a uno, abbiamo bisogno solo di un singolo gate perché il QFT è solo un'operazione Hadamard in questo caso.
Se M è almeno due, questi sono
i gate di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Prima abbiamo bisogno di SM meno uno gate per la trasformata di Fourier
quantistica su M meno uno qubit, qualunque sia quel numero.
Abbiamo anche bisogno di M meno uno
gate di fase controllati, M meno uno gate swap,
e un gate Hadamard aggiuntivo.
Quindi ecco un'espressione
di SM in entrambi i casi quando M è uguale a uno e
quando M è almeno due.
Questo è un esempio di quella che si chiama una relazione di ricorrenza e
appaiono molto comunemente nell'analisi degli algoritmi.
Questo in particolare
è molto semplice e ha una cosiddetta
espressione in forma chiusa, che possiamo ottenere sommando.
Per essere precisi, il valore di SM è la somma dei primi M
interi dispari consecutivi, che è uguale a M quadrato,
come potresti aver già incontrato prima o forse lo hai notato
ad un certo punto della tua vita.
E risulta essere abbastanza facile dimostrare che questa formula è vera per induzione su M
nel caso tu sia interessato a una dimostrazione formale.
Quindi ecco tutto. Possiamo implementare la
trasformata di Fourier quantistica su M qubit usando M quadrato gate.
Solo un paio di osservazioni aggiuntive molto
brevi.
Prima non abbiamo effettivamente
bisogno di tutti i gate swap che ho descritto.
È possibile spingerli effettivamente
tutti alla fine purché adeguiamo su quali qubit i gate di fase controllati
agiscono in modo appropriato.
E se lo facciamo avremo bisogno solo
di M su due gate swap in totale arrotondando verso il basso.
Avremo ancora un costo quadratico, ma il numero di gate può essere ridotto in questo modo comunque.
E un'osservazione finale è che possiamo effettivamente rendere il costo anche inferiore se siamo disposti ad accontentarci di
un'approssimazione abbastanza buona.
Ad esempio, quando M diventa grande, molti dei gate di fase controllati sono abbastanza vicini all'operazione
identità,
ed eliminare
quelli molto vicini può risparmiarci parecchio sui gate mantenendo comunque
un'approssimazione abbastanza buona.
È anche possibile approssimare la trasformata di Fourier quantistica
con circuit molto superficiali, cioè con piccola profondità, nel caso in cui sia qualcosa
che vogliamo fare.
E ora che sappiamo cos'è la
trasformata di Fourier quantistica per diverse dimensioni, così come come può essere implementata quando la dimensione è una potenza di due,
possiamo tornare alla
procedura di stima della fase e vedere come può essere generalizzata dove usiamo un numero arbitrario
M di qubit di controllo.
Ecco come appare la procedura come circuit quantistico per
una scelta arbitraria di M.
Abbiamo M qubit di controllo in alto, che assumiamo siano tutti
inizializzati allo stato zero.
Applichiamo un gate Hadamard
a ciascuno di essi e poi ciascuno di essi è
usato come qubit di controllo per applicare una qualche potenza dell'operazione unitaria U,
WEBVTT
dove raddoppiamo il numero
di volte in cui U viene applicato per ogni qubit di controllo.
Qui in questo diagramma ho indicato questo includendo le potenze
su U all'interno dei riquadri invece di mostrare il gate U controllato
applicato quel numero di volte, come modo sia di rendere
il diagramma più chiaro che di risparmiare spazio così
che si adatti allo schermo.
Ora la prima cosa che dobbiamo notare
riguardo a questa procedura è che potrebbe diventare molto costosa.
In particolare stiamo
raddoppiando il numero di volte in cui ogni operazione U viene applicata
per ogni qubit di controllo.
E se il modo in cui lo facciamo è semplicemente iterare un gate U controllato per quante volte necessitiamo,
otterremo un circuit enorme. Sarà esponenzialmente
grande nel numero M.
Questa è una limitazione importante in generale, e in particolare limita la nostra capacità di ottenere approssimazioni precise
degli autovalori.
Nel caso specifico della fattorizzazione però, a cui arriveremo presto, si scopre che siamo molto fortunati e possiamo usare un trucco che ci permette
di evitare questo aumento esponenziale del costo.
Ma in generale per operazioni
unitarie arbitrarie U, questo non sarà possibile e
pagheremo un prezzo elevato
per aumentare il
numero di qubit di controllo.
Non farò
un'analisi dettagliata del circuit in questo video e invece menzionerò solo che esiste un'espressione abbastanza semplice per lo stato
appena prima delle misurazioni mostrata qui sullo schermo.
Da quello stato possiamo ottenere un'espressione per le probabilità
dei vari risultati, ed è simile a questa.
E una volta che abbiamo questa espressione,
possiamo ragionarci sopra, e davvero questa espressione
è tutto ciò di cui abbiamo bisogno per andare avanti.
Come ho detto, non entrerò nei
dettagli in questo video, ma puoi trovarli nel
contenuto scritto della lezione e si scopre che non è
effettivamente così complicato,
quindi dagli un'occhiata se sei incline a farlo. Se facciamo l'analisi, quello che troviamo è che la situazione
non è molto diversa
dal caso M uguale a due, tranne che otteniamo più precisione.
In particolare, possiamo pensare
prima alla probabilità di ottenere la migliore o una delle
due migliori approssimazioni,
che possiamo esprimere come abbiamo qui.
Puoi ignorare questo pedice di uno sul valore assoluto se vuoi.
Questo è solo un simbolo che possiamo
usare per ricordarci che stiamo parlando di
approssimazioni sul cerchio dove pensiamo a theta uguale a zero
e theta uguale a uno come uguali. Il punto qui è che
stiamo pensando a qualsiasi scelta di Y che rende Y su due alla potenza M
il più vicino possibile a theta.
E ancora una volta, proprio come
avevamo per il caso M uguale a due, abbiamo la garanzia di ottenere questo risultato Y con probabilità almeno del 40%.
In realtà, la probabilità è
almeno quattro su pi quadro, che è un po' più del 40%.
10 non è una cattiva
approssimazione di pi quadro quando si è di fretta.
E questo è davvero notevole. Di quello che stiamo parlando è ottenere la migliore
approssimazione a theta come frazione Y su due alla potenza M
dove Y è un intero. E stiamo ottenendo la
migliore approssimazione con probabilità superiore al 40%.
Possiamo anche pensare alle
approssimazioni peggiori.
Nello specifico immaginiamo
che Y non sia così buono, e più nello specifico supponiamo
che ci sia una migliore
approssimazione a theta della stessa forma che si trova tra theta e Y su due alla M,
che può essere espressa come
è scritto sullo schermo.
In tal caso la
probabilità di ottenere questo Y sarà relativamente piccola, al massimo 25%.
Sarà in realtà inferiore a quella, ma 25% è quello che otteniamo da
un'analisi abbastanza semplice, ma è sufficiente.
Come esempio. Ecco il grafico che otteniamo quando usiamo tre qubit di controllo
invece di due.
Questa volta sto
tracciando solo le probabilità per i risultati tre, quattro e cinque perché non voglio che
la figura sia troppo confusa.
Quando theta è uguale a
un mezzo ad esempio, abbiamo la garanzia di ottenere il risultato quattro.
E quindi prendiamo la nostra
approssimazione come quattro ottavi o un mezzo perché due alla
potenza tre è otto.
E in questo caso siamo esattamente giusti. E finché theta è più vicino a un mezzo che a, diciamo, tre
ottavi ad esempio,
otteniamo il risultato quattro con una probabilità più alta
del risultato tre.
E con probabilità,
di nuovo più grande del 40%.
Ecco il grafico quando M è uguale a quattro. E le curve sembrano davvero
quasi identiche, tranne che ora ci siamo ingranditi
di un fattore di due.
Quindi ora i risultati tracciati includono sette, otto e nove e stiamo prendendo l'approssimazione come uno di questi numeri
diviso per 16 invece di otto.
E mostrerò ancora un grafico dove aumentiamo a M uguale a cinque.
E di nuovo ci
ingrandiremo di un fattore di due.
Ed eccolo. Di nuovo le curve sembrano
quasi identiche, ma stiamo effettivamente
raddoppiando la nostra precisione.
WEBVTT
E come prima abbiamo ottenuto la migliore approssimazione a theta, con probabilità superiore al 40%.
È abbastanza sorprendente. Ma se il 40% non è sufficiente
come misura di confidenza,
quello che possiamo fare è eseguire la procedura un piccolo numero di volte, e
prendere la moda dei risultati, ovvero quello che
appare più frequentemente.
E se lo facciamo, avremo molto probabilmente una buona approssimazione a theta.
Ricorda tra l'altro che ogni volta che eseguiamo la
procedura di stima della fase abbiamo che l'autovettore
esce invariato.
Quindi è disponibile per eseguire la procedura
più volte in questo modo.
In breve, stiamo raccogliendo
statistiche su theta, e il punto è che facendo questo possiamo ottenere un'approssimazione molto precisa
a theta
con alta confidenza, e non abbiamo bisogno di molte iterazioni della procedura per farlo.
E questo è il funzionamento della procedura di stima
della fase.
Nell'ultima parte della lezione, applicheremo la tecnica
della stima della fase al problema della fattorizzazione degli interi.
Come ho menzionato all'inizio del video, il modo in cui funziona è che consideriamo un problema intermedio noto come il problema del calcolo dell'ordine.
Vedremo come possiamo risolvere
il problema del calcolo dell'ordine usando la stima della fase, e poi discuteremo brevemente come risolvere il problema del calcolo dell'ordine
ci permette di fattorizzare interi in modo efficiente.
La seconda parte è completamente classica e riassumerò solo l'idea
di base in questo video.
Ma iniziamo con il
problema del calcolo dell'ordine.
Prima, abbiamo bisogno di
una pratica notazione.
Per ogni intero positivo N, definiamo ZN come gli interi
da zero a N meno uno.
Ad esempio, Z uno ha un
singolo elemento che è zero, Z due ha elementi zero e uno,
z tre ha elementi zero,
uno e due, e così via.
Quindi ZN è un insieme.
Ma possiamo anche pensarci
come più di un insieme. Possiamo pensare alle operazioni aritmetiche come addizione e moltiplicazione su ZN
definendole modulo N.
Ad esempio, supponiamo
che N sia uguale a sette.
Abbiamo che tre e cinque
sono elementi di Z sette e se li moltiplichiamo otteniamo 15
che lascia un resto di
uno dopo la divisione per sette.
A volte esprimiamo questo scrivendo che tre volte cinque è
congruente a uno modulo sette, come è scritto qui.
Ma possiamo anche semplicemente scrivere che tre volte cinque uguale a uno.
Ovviamente tre volte cinque
normalmente non fa uno, fa 15.
Ma quando è chiaro che
stiamo lavorando in Z sette cioè che la moltiplicazione
è definita modulo sette,
possiamo semplicemente scrivere che
tre volte cinque fa uno.
Ora tra gli elementi
di ZN per qualsiasi N positivo, alcuni di essi avranno
MCD uguale a uno con N
e altri no. E gli elementi che hanno MCD uguale a uno con N sono speciali.
e scriviamo ZN star per riferirci all'insieme di solo questi elementi.
Ad esempio, ecco Z 21 star.
tra gli elementi di Z 21, che sono 21 ovviamente, si scopre che 12 di essi hanno MCD uguale a uno
con 21 e gli altri no.
In particolare ogni volta che
abbiamo un elemento di Z 21 che è divisibile per tre o sette, lo saltiamo.
Ci sono varie ragioni
per cui questo insieme è speciale, e una delle ragioni è che ogni volta che abbiamo un elemento di ZN star
e consideriamo le potenze intere positive di quel numero, alla fine
arriveremo sempre al numero uno,
dove proprio come prima stiamo parlando di moltiplicazione modulo N.
il più piccolo intero positivo alla potenza che ci dà uno è chiamato
l'ordine di quell'elemento.
Ad esempio, considera l'elemento A uguale a quattro in Z 21 star.
quattro volte quattro fa 16, che non è uguale a uno modulo 21, ma se moltiplichiamo per quattro ancora una volta,
otteniamo 64, e 64 modulo
21 è uguale a uno.
Quindi l'ordine di quattro modulo 21 è tre.
Arrivare a uno come questo accade sempre per tutti gli elementi di ZN star.
E tra l'altro, non accade mai
per gli elementi di ZN che non sono in ZN star.
Quindi avere MCD uguale a
uno con N come questo è sia necessario che
sufficiente perché questo accada.
E solo per concludere
l'esempio di N uguale a 21, ecco le più piccole
potenze intere positive per le quali questo funziona per
ogni elemento di Z 21 star,
e possono essere verificate una per una.
E ora possiamo enunciare il
problema del calcolo dell'ordine, che è semplicemente trovare l'ordine per un dato elemento in ZN star.
WEBVTT
Per essere precisi, l'input è
due interi positivi A e N per i quali il MCD è uguale a uno,
e l'output è il
più piccolo intero positivo R tale che A alla potenza R è
congruente a uno modulo N,
o equivalentemente il
più piccolo intero positivo R per il quale A alla R è uguale a uno.
Assumendo che stiamo facendo aritmetica in ZN.
Si ritiene che questo sia un problema
computazionalmente difficile, non è noto nessun algoritmo classico efficiente
per risolverlo.
E come discuteremo il problema è almeno tanto difficile quanto
la fattorizzazione degli interi nel senso che se abbiamo un algoritmo per risolvere il calcolo dell'ordine,
saremmo in grado di usare quell'algoritmo per risolvere il problema della
fattorizzazione degli interi in modo efficiente.
In realtà funziona anche al contrario, nel senso che se hai un algoritmo per la fattorizzazione, puoi usarlo per risolvere
il problema del calcolo dell'ordine.
Quindi i due problemi sono
in un certo senso equivalenti in termini di loro
difficoltà computazionale.
Ora vedremo come possiamo risolvere
il problema del calcolo dell'ordine su un computer quantistico
usando la stima della fase.
Per creare un collegamento tra i problemi, immaginiamo di avere un sistema il cui insieme di stati classici è AN.
Per qualsiasi scelta di un elemento A in ZN star, definiremo un'operazione
MA come abbiamo qui.
In parole quello che MA fa è moltiplicare per A, e qui la moltiplicazione è modulo N.
E per il resto di questa lezione, devi sempre pensare alle
espressioni all'interno dei cat come calcolate modulo N,
solo per semplicità e per non dover continuare a
scrivere mod N ancora e ancora.
Questa è un'operazione unitaria, ma questo è vero solo
perché A è in ZN star.
Se il MCD di A e N non è uno, questa operazione non sarà unitaria.
Ecco un esempio. Se N è uguale a 15 e A è uguale a due, che è in Z 15 star, allora
questa è l'azione di M due.
E se esamini questo
esempio per qualche momento, vedrai che quello che sta accadendo è che gli elementi di ZN vengono semplicemente permutati da questa azione.
Quindi è sia deterministica che unitaria, il che vuol dire che come matrice, MA è una matrice di permutazione.
Ed ecco l'idea principale. Gli autovalori di MA sono
strettamente connessi
con l'ordine di A. E usando la stima della fase per approssimare questi
autovalori abbastanza da vicino
possiamo determinare l'ordine di A. Quindi quali sono esattamente gli autovettori e gli autovalori di MA?
Beh, non abbiamo bisogno di tutti, ne abbiamo bisogno solo di alcuni.
Iniziamo con un esempio facile.
Ecco un autovettore di MA, l'abbiamo chiamato size zero, ed è dato dalla
somma di cat uno, cat a,
cat A quadrato, e così via fino a cat A alla potenza R meno uno, tutti divisi per la radice quadrata di R
per renderlo un vettore unitario. Qui R è l'ordine di A.
E riserverò la
lettera R per l'ordine di A per il resto della lezione.
Quindi ogni volta che vedi R, è l'ordine di A per
qualsiasi A di cui stiamo parlando.
L'autovalore associato
a questo autovettore è uno.
E possiamo verificarlo
applicando MA a questo vettore per vedere cosa otteniamo.
MA moltiplica per A, quindi
dobbiamo solo aumentare ciascuno degli esponenti di
uno e questo è ciò che otteniamo.
Ma l'ordine di A è R, quindi A alla potenza R fa uno.
E possiamo fare quella sostituzione.
Ma è lo stesso vettore
con cui siamo partiti. Tutto quello che abbiamo fatto è
mescolare i cat ma stiamo prendendo la somma quindi
questo non cambia nulla.
Quindi MA volte psi zero è uguale a psi zero.
Quindi è un autovettore di
MA con autovalore uno.
Questo è un esempio molto semplice
di autovettore e per identificarne altri, richiamiamo la stessa notazione che avevamo prima nella lezione.
Omega R è il numero complesso
sul cerchio unitario che otteniamo prendendo E alla
potenza di due volte pi volte I
diviso per R. L'ultima volta avevamo N invece di R, ma funziona allo stesso modo
per R al posto di N.
Abbiamo bisogno di questo numero perché
apparirà negli altri autovettori
di MA che identificheremo.
E ora che abbiamo richiamato quella notazione, possiamo osservare che questo
vettore chiamato psi uno è anche un autovettore di MA.
È simile a psi zero, abbiamo esattamente gli stessi cat e li stiamo sommando e
dividendo per la radice di R.
Ma questa volta abbiamo varie fasi che moltiplicano ciascuno dei cat.
Omega R alla meno uno per A, omega R alla meno due per A quadrato, e così via fino a omega R alla
potenza meno R meno uno
per A alla potenza R meno uno. Quindi la potenza di omega R
è sempre meno uno volte qualsiasi potenza di A
appare all'interno del cat.
Non lo esaminerò in dettaglio, ma è mostrato sullo schermo nel caso tu voglia rivedere il video e mettere in pausa se necessario.
Ma se facciamo la moltiplicazione e semplifichiaamo di nuovo usando il fatto che A alla potenza R è uguale a uno
così come il fatto molto importante che omega alla potenza R è uguale a uno, quello che troveremo è che abbiamo
di nuovo un autovettore di MA.
WEBVTT
Questa volta mentre facciamo la semplificazione, dovremo estrarre un fattore di omega R per vedere che abbiamo effettivamente un autovettore
e quel vettore omega R rappresenta l'autovalore associato a questo autovettore.
Quindi questa è una seconda coppia autovettore
autovalore di NA.
Possiamo identificare ulteriori autovettori usando esattamente lo stesso ragionamento, E in effetti, se semplicemente sostituiamo omega R
con omega R alla potenza J per ogni J tra zero e R meno uno, otterremo sempre un autovettore,
e l'autovalore associato sarà omega R alla potenza J.
Quindi questo include effettivamente
psi zero e pis uno, che abbiamo già visto
così come R meno due, altre coppie autovettore autovalore.
Funzionano tutti fondamentalmente allo stesso modo, e per verificarli, dobbiamo solo sapere che A alla potenza R fa uno
così come omega R alla
potenza R fa uno.
Ci sono altri autovettori di MA come cat zero ad esempio, ma non ci saranno utili e non dobbiamo preoccuparcene.
Dobbiamo preoccuparci solo di psi zero attraverso psi R meno uno.
Concentriamoci su psi uno per un momento, solo per cercare di capire perché ci interessa questi autovettori
e cosa possono dirci
sull'ordine R, che è quello che stiamo cercando di trovare.
Supponendo che ci venga dato
l'autovettore psi uno, possiamo tentare di imparare
R nel modo seguente.
Prima, eseguiamo la stima
della fase su questo autovettore usando un circuit quantistico che
implementa l'operazione MA.
Quello che otteniamo è un'approssimazione a theta, che è uno su R in questo caso.
E secondo perché stiamo cercando R e abbiamo un'approssimazione a uno su R, la cosa naturale da fare è
calcolare il reciproco
e arrotondarlo all'intero
più vicino. Dobbiamo arrotondare in questo modo
perché R deve essere un intero.
Ma non abbiamo uno su R esattamente, abbiamo solo un'approssimazione ad esso.
Ma se l'approssimazione è abbastanza buona, otterremo R quando arrotondiamo,
che è quello che stiamo cercando.
E ora la domanda è quanta precisione ci serve per determinare correttamente R calcolando il reciproco e arrotondando?
O in altre parole, quanto accurata deve essere la nostra
approssimazione per far funzionare tutto questo?
Beh, si scopre che abbiamo bisogno di un'approssimazione abbastanza precisa.
Ad esempio, non possiamo
permetterci di confondere uno su R con uno su R più uno, o uno su R meno uno ad esempio.
In queste due frazioni, uno su R più uno e
uno su R meno uno sono abbastanza vicini a uno
su R quando R è grande.
Ma sebbene abbiamo bisogno di
un'approssimazione abbastanza accurata, non abbiamo bisogno di un'approssimazione ridicolmente
accurata, e può essere dimostrato che
se la nostra approssimazione
soddisfa la disuguaglianza che
abbiamo qui sullo schermo, allora arrotondare ci
darà la risposta giusta.
Non cercherò di argomentarlo in questo video, ma è mostrato nel materiale
scritto della lezione nel caso tu sia interessato ai dettagli.
E se questa è la precisione
che stiamo cercando, allora è sufficiente usare un
numero di qubit di controllo nella procedura di stima della fase
che è uguale a due volte
la lunghezza di N più uno.
Dove come avevamo nelle lezioni precedenti, la lunghezza di N è il numero di bit di cui abbiamo bisogno per esprimere N in binario.
Tra l'altro, se siamo soddisfatti
di ottenere la migliore approssimazione con probabilità almeno del 40% e non cerchiamo di
aumentare la nostra confidenza
come ho descritto prima, allora non abbiamo effettivamente bisogno del più uno.
Ma in ogni caso, abbiamo che il numero
di qubit di controllo di cui abbiamo bisogno è lineare nella lunghezza di N
scritta come stringa binaria.
Abbiamo visto che se abbiamo
l'autovettore psi uno, possiamo usare la stima della fase per trovare R, purché usiamo abbastanza precisione.
Purtroppo non è così facile mettere le mani su questo autovettore.
Quindi poniamoci una domanda diversa.
Supponiamo di non avere psi uno, ma di avere psi
per una scelta casuale di J.
Possiamo ancora capire qual è R? O almeno possiamo
capire qualcosa su R?
E la risposta è sì, possiamo capire qualcosa
su R, almeno in media.
Quello che possiamo fare è cercare
di capire J su R usando un metodo molto simile
a quello che abbiamo appena visto,
ma con una differenza fondamentale.
Prima, faremo esattamente la
stessa cosa che abbiamo fatto prima, che è eseguire la procedura di stima
della fase sull'autovettore psi J.
E quello che otterremo è un'approssimazione
a J su R, al contrario di uno su R,
che era quello che avevamo prima.
Ma ora abbiamo un piccolo problema, perché calcolare il
reciproco non ci darà R, ci darà R su J.
E tra l'altro, non
assumiamo di sapere qual è J, ci viene dato semplicemente psi J per un J casuale,
e non ci viene detto qual è J. Quindi cosa possiamo fare?
Beh, si scopre che esiste un noto
algoritmo classico che può aiutarci, chiamato l'algoritmo delle frazioni continue.
E quello che può fare questo algoritmo è prendere la nostra approssimazione
Y su due alla M e dirci quale frazione U su V,
scritta ai minimi termini, e dove U e V sono entrambi
interi minori di N è più vicina alla nostra approssimazione.
WEBVTT
È un algoritmo davvero affascinante, e se ti interessa, dovresti assolutamente esplorarlo.
È strettamente connesso all'algoritmo di Euclide per
il calcolo del MCD infatti.
Ma non dirò altro
su di esso in questo video.
Il punto è che se abbiamo una buona
approssimazione a qualche frazione per la quale numeratore e
denominatore non sono troppo grandi,
l'algoritmo può recuperare la frazione, e questo è ciò che stiamo facendo qui.
E ora ci ritroviamo esattamente
con la stessa domanda di prima, che è quanta precisione ci serve?
E si scopre che
esattamente lo stesso limite che avevamo prima funziona in questo caso.
E quindi scegliere M esattamente
allo stesso modo di prima funziona anche qui.
Ora questo non ci dirà necessariamente
R.
Quello che impareremo se usiamo
abbastanza precisione, è J su R, ma sarà una
frazione ai minimi termini.
Quindi potremmo essere sfortunati nel senso che questa scelta casuale di J potrebbe avere fattori comuni con R,
e ci saranno nascosti. Nel caso peggiore ad esempio, potremmo ottenere J uguale a zero e non impareremo assolutamente nulla.
Ma questo è letteralmente l'unico
caso in cui non impariamo nulla.
In generale, otterremo almeno
un fattore non banale di R, e se siamo in grado di estrarre campioni casuali
e ottenere psi J per diverse scelte di J, possiamo in realtà recuperare
R con alta probabilità calcolando il minimo comune multiplo
di tutti i denominatori
che osserviamo. E questo in realtà non
richiede molto campioni.
Il punto finale è che alcune scelte di J nasconderanno fattori di R, ma scelte casuali di J
non saranno in grado di nascondere i
fattori di R a lungo.
Quindi questa è l'idea. Rimane da considerare l'implementazione e in particolare capire
quanto costa.
L'essenza dell'idea, per calcolare l'ordine di un
dato elemento A e ZN star è applicare la procedura di stima della fase
all'operazione MA.
Capiamo quale
è il costo di farlo come funzione della lunghezza di N maiuscola, che indicherò con n minuscola.
Ecco un circuit per la stima della fase. Avremo bisogno di n minuscola qubit nella parte bassa del circuit
per codificare elementi di ZN in binario. Quindi abbiamo N qubit di controllo in alto e n minuscola qubit in basso,
il che è bello perché corrisponde ai nomi che
abbiamo usato prima nella lezione.
Per contare il
numero di gate di cui abbiamo bisogno per l'intero circuit, concentriamoci prima sul costo delle operazioni unitarie controllate.
Se usiamo le tecniche
dalla lezione precedente, la lezione sei, possiamo implementare MA usando O grande di n minuscola quadrato gate
usando algoritmi classici efficienti per l'aritmetica modulo N.
Salterò i dettagli in questo video, ma come diverse altre
cose di cui ho parlato, puoi leggere di più nel materiale scritto della lezione.
Non è sufficiente però
implementare solo MA.
Dobbiamo anche implementare MA quadrato, MA alla quarta potenza, alla
ottava potenza, e così via
fino a MA a una potenza che è esponenziale in M.
E sappiamo che dovremo prendere M lineare in n minuscola
per ottenere sufficiente precisione.
Questa è una grande preoccupazione,
e l'ho sollevata prima.
Se dovessimo implementare le potenze
di MA semplicemente iterando MA, avremmo problemi perché tutte queste iterazioni di MA
comporterebbero un costo esponenziale.
Fortunatamente, possiamo usare un trucco per evitare questo aumento di costo.
Quello che possiamo fare è il seguente, per ogni potenza K di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Prima, calcoliamo A alla
potenza K, modulo N.
Questo è il problema dell'esponenziazione modulare che ho menzionato nella lezione sei.
E può essere risolto efficientemente. E questo è qualcosa che possiamo fare con un computer classico.
Questo calcolo non
ha bisogno di essere eseguito da un circuit quantistico.
Quindi facciamo che B sia il risultato.
Quindi B è un elemento di ZN star.
E secondo, al posto di MA alla potenza K, usiamo semplicemente un circuit per MB.
E questo è tutto. B è solo un elemento di ZN star, quindi il costo per implementare MB
è O grande di n minuscola quadrato.
In sintesi, quello che stiamo facendo è esponenziare in ZN invece di esponenziare
un circuit quantistico.
Ma l'operazione effettiva che
otteniamo è la stessa in entrambi i modi. È semplicemente la moltiplicazione per A, K volte.
Questo è una specie di miracolo in effetti. E non saremmo in grado di
risolvere il problema del calcolo dell'ordine o fattorizzare interi efficientemente
con un computer quantistico
se non fosse per questo.
E ora che sappiamo che ciascuna delle operazioni unitarie controllate, incluse le potenze, può essere implementata
a costo O grande di N quadrato, possiamo contare il totale
numero di gate di cui abbiamo bisogno.
Abbiamo N gate Hadamard, e poiché M è uguale
a O grande di n minuscola, il costo è O grande di n minuscola.
WEBVTT
Abbiamo M operazioni unitarie controllate che hanno ciascuna costo O grande di N quadrato.
Quindi il costo totale qui
è O grande di N al cubo.
E infine, la trasformata di Fourier quantistica ha costo O grande di n quadrato.
Quindi il costo totale è O grande di N al cubo.
In particolare, vediamo che anche con il nostro
trucco dell'esponenziazione modulare, il costo delle operazioni unitarie controllate domina.
Ma comunque, il costo
è polinomiale in n minuscola.
Ci sono anche alcuni calcoli classici
richiesti, come il calcolo delle esponenziazioni modulari e l'esecuzione dell'algoritmo delle frazioni continue,
ma quei calcoli
hanno anche costo polinomiale. E in effetti, possono essere fatti in O grande di N al cubo operazioni anch'essi.
C'è solo un problema rimanente, ed è che dobbiamo mettere le mani su uno di questi autovettori.
Come possiamo farlo?
La soluzione è in realtà molto semplice. Non eseguiamo il circuit
su un autovettore.
Lo eseguiamo semplicemente sullo stato uno, ovvero la codifica
binaria del numero uno, che stiamo pensando
come un elemento di ZN.
Quindi facciamo quella
sostituzione nel diagramma.
La ragione per cui funziona è questa equazione qui.
Lo stato cat uno è
in effetti una sovrapposizione uniforme degli R autovettori di cui
abbiamo parlato.
E questo non è immediatamente ovvio, ma se calcoli la
somma, dovresti ottenere cat uno.
E se eseguiamo il circuit su questo stato, l'output che otterremo
sarà esattamente lo stesso di se avessimo scelto casualmente J
e eseguito la procedura sull'
autovettore psi J.
Di nuovo, non è ovvio, ma un'analisi rivela che è vero.
E infine, questo è tutto. Abbiamo un algoritmo quantistico efficiente
per il calcolo dell'ordine.
C'è una parte molto breve
della lezione rimasta e riguarda il rapporto tra la fattorizzazione degli interi
e il calcolo dell'ordine.
Ho menzionato che se possiamo risolvere il problema del calcolo dell'ordine in modo efficiente, allora possiamo anche fattorizzare
interi in modo efficiente.
E voglio darti molto brevemente l'idea principale di come funziona.
È completamente classico. Questa parte non ha nulla
a che fare con il calcolo quantistico.
Ecco un metodo per trovare
un fattore non banale di un dato intero positivo N.
E tra l'altro, questo metodo funziona solo quando N è un numero dispari, e non è un numero primo
elevato a una potenza.
Quei due casi quando N
è pari o una potenza prima possono essere gestiti separatamente.
Ci sono metodi classici efficienti sia per rilevare che per
gestire quei due casi.
Questo metodo è probabilistico. Potrebbe fallire, ma la
probabilità di fallimento sarà al massimo un mezzo,
e possiamo semplicemente eseguirlo
più volte indipendentemente per ridurre la probabilità
di errore in modo esponenzialmente rapido.
Prima, scegliamo A tra
due e N meno uno a caso, uniformemente.
Poi calcoliamo il MCD di A e N.
E se il MCD risulta
essere maggiore di uno, siamo stati incredibilmente fortunati.
Il MCD sarà un fattore di N e possiamo semplicemente restituirlo e fermarci.
Altrimenti, l'algoritmo continua e ora sappiamo che A è in ZN star.
E ora calcoliamo l'ordine di A, che è dove abbiamo bisogno di un computer quantistico.
O forse abbiamo un modo diverso
per calcolare l'ordine. L'algoritmo non si preoccupa davvero di dove viene da, ma l'unico modo che conosciamo
per farlo efficientemente
è con un computer quantistico.
Se l'ordine di R è pari, allora calcoliamo il MCD di
A alla potenza R su due meno uno con N.
E se quel MCD è maggiore di uno, allora di nuovo abbiamo un fattore di N, quindi lo restituiamo e ci fermiamo.
Altrimenti l'algoritmo ha fallito. E in quel caso, possiamo
tornare all'inizio e scegliere un A diverso
e sperare in un risultato migliore
la prossima volta.
E questo è tutto. E tra l'altro, una volta
trovato un fattore di N, possiamo ricorrere su quel fattore
e dividere per quel fattore finché non abbiamo una fattorizzazione prima di N.
Quindi perché dovrebbe funzionare?
Beh, ci sono due punti principali. Il primo è che poiché A alla potenza R è congruente a uno modulo N,
abbiamo che N divide A
alla potenza R meno uno.
Queste due affermazioni
sono in realtà equivalenti. Questa è la definizione di mod N che troverai nei libri di teoria dei numeri.
Secondo, se R è pari, allora questa equazione che
abbiamo qui è vera.
Questa è la nota formula
per una differenza di quadrati.
In realtà, l'equazione è vera per tutti i valori di R, ma abbiamo bisogno che R su due sia
un intero nel passaggio quattro.
WEBVTT
E quindi se mettiamo insieme i due fatti, vediamo che ogni fattore primo di N deve dividere una delle due
espressioni tra parentesi,
perché è l'unico modo
in cui N può dividere il prodotto.
Ora, potrebbe essere che ogni
singolo fattore primo di N divida la prima
espressione tra parentesi e non la seconda, ma per il nostro A casuale,
questo non è molto probabile. E quindi quando calcoliamo
il MCD nel passaggio quattro, è probabile che otteniamo il prodotto
di alcuni dei fattori primi
di N, ma non tutti.
Per analizzare questo attentamente
ci vuole un po' di teoria dei numeri, ma è una teoria dei numeri abbastanza elementare.
Quindi se trovi la teoria dei numeri
interessante e vuoi saperne di più, prova a lavorare su questa analisi.
Lavorare su cose come questa è un ottimo modo per imparare di più, ma lascio questo a te.
E questa è la fine della lezione. In questa lezione, abbiamo coperto
il problema della stima della fase, come possiamo risolverlo in modo efficiente
su un computer quantistico,
e come possiamo applicare la soluzione per ottenere un algoritmo quantistico a costo polinomiale per la fattorizzazione degli interi.
Spero che ti unirai a me per la prossima lezione, che riguarda l'algoritmo di ricerca quantistica di Grover.
Arrivederci alla prossima.